hey guys and welcome back to City
skylines now I want to talk about the
fact that I haven't actually uploaded a
video in this series in about a week and
it's basically because I was still have
a cold and it doesn't really matter too
much but it the pain issue is just that
my voice was way too bad to actually
record a video and me being me I was
very well if ill-prepared you could say
and didn't actually have a pre-recorded
video so I couldn't really record
anything
and that's why I've taught up in silence
on the channel for a little bit but now
I feel like my voice is decent enough to
at least get into the commentary of this
video but I should still say that my
voice isn't entirely great yet and even
though I'll edit out these sniffs and
coughs it might just sort of slowly
deteriorate over the course of this
video and also I didn't actually prepare
much for the commentary of this video
like usually I watch the video and take
some notes of stuff that I could talk
about and what's actually happening but
I didn't do that today so hopefully I'll
be able to actually rationalize my
choices afterwards still without knowing
what's coming entirely but it might just
turn out to be a little bit messy so
hopefully you can at least enjoy the
time-lapse but keep in mind that the
commentary won't quite be really great
today anyway something that I wanted to
do in this episode is to get to adding a
couple new residential neighborhoods in
the city and it's more or less in the
style of what I already had but still
messing with some different shapes here
and there like getting these row houses
over here but setting up something that
you quite often do you see in many of
these newer neighborhoods in the
Netherlands it's not only that they are
very small scaled as somebody also
commented on in the last video
many of the new neighborhoods aren't
planned in the vast large stretches of
land as they used to be but are more
small developments that sort of grow
more naturally over time as well but
what you also very commonly see is that
you still have these very straight Road
patterns with the row houses attached to
them but there's a lot of play
with these straight roads so you have
some slightly crooked roads that have a
very slight curve in them or you do have
these straight roads but there is a sort
of diagonal road going through it and
that's also something that I do want to
play with in this episode and also the
next ones and sort of just what this
little parts over here was a little bit
inspired by to be quite honest I just
had to fill the space between the city
centre and the rail and really the only
thing I figured that would make sense
was just a couple of areas with houses
that could just be a bit a little bit of
the early 90s late 90s maybe some zeros
as well but just some houses that could
fit in there with some smaller small
skilled neighborhoods something that I
was looking for over here
I'll also be playing a little bit with
different ways of making neighborhoods
in this area in this area specifically
as I want to get a small area actually
with detached houses and cul-de-sacs
because that's something that you do see
in the Netherlands and are sort of
similar to the American suburbs you
don't really see them as often but it's
definitely something that you do
sometimes see for example you have these
very typical cold ASEC neighborhoods in
O'Meara for instance and that's
something that I wanted to have even if
just in a small scale in the city as
well but yeah that'll just be about the
majority of this video not too much
interesting is really going on I think
the next episode will be about can I
give that away I think I can next
episode will be about another new
neighbourhood area but alongside the
river and actually playing a lot with
how water works which you can probably
tell is quite honestly one of the ways
in which I just kind of like to practice
an experiment a bit with different ways
in which you see neighborhoods in the
Netherlands like getting to different
shapes and different things that you've
seen in neighborhoods and sort of want
to develop and practice with that over
time so next episode will just be about
getting the water physics to actually
listen to what I try to do which it
probably wants
and actually getting one of these
waterside and also very heavily whatever
focused neighborhoods which you do quite
often see though i won't quite get into
floating houses definitely want to try
and work with some smaller canals and
dikes and things like that and then the
episode after that i think is the
university but don't quote me on that
time not 100% sure anyway that is that
over here with these three flats i
really just wanted to make sure and this
is one of the things where I feel it is
actually very hard to successfully
simulate a Dutch city especially when it
comes to the 90s or later neighborhoods
because something which you very
commonly see is these apartment blocks
these flats which have a very distinct
design but they have a design that goes
along with the row houses around them
and that's something that you can't
really get in since obviously all of
these assets are made by different
people but in the Netherlands what you
would quite often see is that they use
the same materials the same types of
bricks and collars and overall style
accents things like that in the flats
that they use in the houses around them
and the flats are also very low and
having more spread out design and are
really spread over what would be many
tiles in this game and it's something
that I can very well impossibly actually
get in here
so when it comes to the apartment blocks
as much as I would wish to actually
integrate apartment blocks in a
realistic way into living areas I really
want to keep it mainly focused on row
houses because it's just the more easy
thing to do
hold on let me take a sip of water and
yeah that's basically about that that's
basically also why it took such a very
long time to get the exact appointments
that I was looking for alongside the
rail over there what I might not like
too much is that really recurring theme
of three different of three identical
buildings in a row alongside the rail
but then again I kind of like it alright
so I'll try to fight my
self here and actually talk a little
less because I feel my voice slowly
dying this is the area where I wanted to
add the little cul-de-sac area with the
detached houses not quite in a way in
which you would find detached houses
alongside dikes or just all the parts of
towns but one of these modern areas
where people decide that this is gonna
be where all the rich people live and
that's basically how I wanted to fill
this in also really just playing with
this overall type of building roads and
seeing how it would work out and if I
would like it over here which I think I
kind of do and they are still going to
have the same style of all having the
same houses so it's gonna be similar to
american-style suburbs in that way so
even though these houses are standalone
and not actual row houses they are still
in that planned predetermined way and
they all still should look the same in
the end though I do have to say there
are a couple of things which I should
really thank a lot of people about now
actually a number of things that I
wanted to thank people about in this
episode but I probably forget about all
of them so I might return to that in the
future but I get so many comments about
the moats that I actually already have
but don't actually use correctly or to
their fullest potential all the time and
those comments are amazing because
they're real wake-up calls as to what I
can actually get done and one of those
instances would be the fact that I've
already got precision engineering for
such a long time but didn't actually use
all those shortcuts to make it work that
well
but now I can tell you actually did pick
it up or at least I picked it up
mentally as in finally understood where
all the shortcuts were and well actually
use it in the future as well and I'll
actually get the no Pillars mod in the
future too because this was my original
point that I wanted to talk about like
the next minute or it is probably a bit
less but the next little bit who were
spent trying to get the exact same house
is over here just because there was no
other way than just randomly spawning to
get them to be the exact houses that I
wanted since the color sexes don't
actually allow you to just I drop houses
onto them
but at the moment I didn't realize that
using the no pillows multi you could
just make sure that houses can be placed
alongside the road even if they
technically can't be placed because the
grid shape doesn't allow it now this is
just purely from the future and I mean
really from the future
but in the last episode I complain about
not having after dark and oh boy this is
actually really awkward so what actually
happened the next day now I think it's
actually the very day that I uploaded
episode 9 I went onto the Steam Workshop
and bought myself after dark and figured
well finally about damn time but what
happened next was that actually the next
day I got like I woke up and I found
that two people actually gifted me after
dark and I felt so bad about that
because they were like I saw you didn't
have off the dark yet so I wanted to
give it to you so you could make videos
about it I was like [ __ ] I just bought
it yesterday so yeah I really have to
give a shout-out to all the people who
even gifted me games because that's
never happened to me before and of
course I just feel like who gives games
to random strangers on the internet and
why me
but the thing is I have after dark at
the moment but it won't actually feature
in future episodes too soon I don't know
the exact episode in which you actually
use it but I wanted to not use it yet
since it didn't work for me which is due
to the fact that one of my assets is
incompatible with after dark but I quite
frankly didn't quite feel like going
through all of the hundreds of assets
that I have just to find that one or two
or three assets that didn't work with
off the dark so I decided that for the
time being I to Anna keep it just with
the normal game but I'll get into after
dark in a little while don't know in
which exact episode but I'll definitely
get there and replace all the pedestrian
parts or at least many of the pedestrian
paths that I do a replace with bicycle
paths just for realism purposes with
bicycle paths and I might actually want
to
get into detail of that in the same
episode in which I want to attack all
public transportation in general
primarily the bus routes which is still
something that I do plan on making a
real-time section for in the future
anyway a small introduction about this
curved part over here it was actually
quite funny because I first had the
curve next to the cul-de-sac
neighborhood over there and just figured
that would look cool and actually work
well with the shape that I had over
there because it's such a weird triangle
and it's hard to fit neighborhoods into
triangles so randomly Jesus had that
curved shape over there and then I
figured that I could actually continue
that curve into half a circle over here
which I do think in the end worked out
wonderfully but that's already the
second half circle in this city which is
going to start to perhaps be a little
bit of an overkill but yeah this is much
like the neighborhood in the episode 9
yup it is it is really one of the
standard circular neighbourhoods with
different types of row houses in each
layer of the circle they're kind of like
onions or ogres if you will and in the
middle over here I just wanted to make
sure to add one of these very small
little stop shopping and elementary
school and general services districts
because since I can't actually get in
the realistic touch shopping areas the
small shopping streets and malls that
you usually find I do in a stick with
the very common formula of having these
areas here and there where you just
cluster a couple of main surfaces
together like some schools and
supermarkets and this is this is the
thing you can realistically to some
extent to in the game so that's why I
wanted to have these buildings over here
it just seemed like a good central place
to have this but yeah that's basically
what happened in general in this episode
of my again thank you so much for
watching already in this episode which
probably had the worst commentary ever
for the series hopefully I will be fine
again soon because I don't really mind
anything but just loose
my voice is really annoying with this
entire hobby of doing YouTube and thanks
for watching again see late